do you guys watch your anime
we want a segue I do actually I was a
bit of a when I was growing up I loved
Ohio mazaki I still really like it yeah
Ghibli gilby films
and then I watched a lot of Naruto
um I watched bleach uh oh hell yeah I
watched one uh one piece I watched um
Death Note nice how much did you watch
because that's uh you know when you say
you watch One Piece that that means a
lot of things yeah how far did you I
didn't watch that much one piece I
watched a lot of Naruto I watched like
Seven Seasons eight seasons it was like
a hundred I think it was like 160 180 I
was up to yeah that's that's a lot like
300 episodes
which is like the longest season how far
did you get
I don't remember where I got up to but
yeah around 180 or something I remember
[__] no there's a lot yeah yeah
that's that's a that's a lot of episodes
more than Connor yeah
I was I mean like barely I I watched
heaps of it doesn't even count I watched
heaps of Dragon Ball Z yeah Pokemon
doesn't give us like that but before
before coming on here I'm like I got I
gotta do the crash course I gotta go
um literally well I just ended up
watching The Studio Ghibli films again
but um but um no what I did find was
Cowboy Bebop and I'm like this is the
coolest thing I've ever seen oh hell
yeah I was like what have I been doing
all my life it's like yeah yeah I loved
it yeah yeah it's good what's annoying
have you watched the new um what's the
the what's the one that's copied off the
computer game um
I was just like this is just Cowboy
Bebop but worst yeah
because it's just bounty hunters
uh I don't know you don't think so I I I
I I you know
that's the first time I've ever heard
that comparison I I liked it I I I I've
made that comparison as well uh but I
actually prefer cyberpunk I don't know I
I think I think I will Bebop is great
but I like having like an ongoing
storyline oh yeah yeah Cowboy Bebop was
just like every episode like
self-contained yeah yeah uh and though
you know that was cool they had some
like really cool [__] ideas but
cyberpunk was just like a group of
bounty hunters and you see their Journey
from like beginning to end and yeah yeah
that was cool some of those scenes
that's cool yeah yeah some of those
scenes in a cyberfunk were just so
insane the opening scene of the shows
yeah yeah yeah those scenes were just
awesome yeah did you play the game as
well to that no I didn't my brother
played it but he just complained about
the glitches it was so bad I'm not
touching this
also it's hard with video games because
like I get obsessed and if I if I
download it I'm just not gonna make
videos every day
well you've never seen Spirited Away no
I just know all the screenshots
I've never seen uh Princess Mononoke I
think I lied and said I saw it one time
on the podcast I felt pressured to watch
it
I've watched a lot of them actually wow
yeah I mean you're not a real Studio
Ghibli fan are you Connor no yeah I've
just talked about this before but how
many seconds have a dick yeah
this is like this is like my my thing
like my uh some people are like that's
[__] based but I don't know why this
pissed me off so much his son made a
movie and he went to the premiere and he
walked out halfway through it I was like
it is literally a scene he walks out of
the cinema lights a cigarette he's like
he's still got a long way to go he's
like he's still not ready Cool that's
like an anime
[__]
you just got to be like all right all
right you know your son comes back with
a drawing and like it's like hey hey Dad
I made this bro you know they're like
five years old or something you know
it's like a [__] drawing all right do
you do you lie and say this is amazing
son well if they're five yeah but like
you know yeah
nicely it's got to be a bit of
encouragement with a bit of oh you could
be better this could be better you know
like I don't know it's the fact that he
didn't even like tell his son it was
[__] he just walks out you know he just
walks out now he is the dad that went
out for cigarettes and never came back
yeah that makes me like him more
yeah people hear that and you like him
more I think that's awesome yeah it's
like it's like Jackie Chan you know have
you have you ever like heard about his
son's life oh yeah yeah yeah it's under
drugs right that's very illegal yeah
yeah he was like he was like the
Ambassador for like and like anti-drugs
on like he's like I did not claim my son
yeah yeah yeah and his son got caught
like doing weed or something yeah uh in
his apartment and uh yeah the more I
found out the more I found out about it
the more I found out yo he just wasn't
there for his kids no he was he was just
never oh yeah he was just a [__] dad
um
if you're gonna be a bad father he
probably picked the coolest way to do it
like the stuff he was doing when he
wasn't with his kids
for Humanity yeah like we got sick films
a lot of bad dads are just like I don't
know doing drugs somewhere like this
yeah
my dad's a bad daddy he doesn't even
know how to do cool fight choreography
I guess he gets out the nunchucks
I when I was a child I like hold on
hold on hold up hold up hold up when I
was four I don't know 16 I was like oh
yeah hentai's cool
not for me not for me anymore I missed I
missed out on hentai I feel like I
watched like cartoon porn as a as a team
but I needed for like [__] like Marge
Simpson yeah exactly that's exactly what
it is
it's the weird ads you see yeah
you watched those yeah I did when I was
a kid it died look it doesn't do it for
me anymore but like I I the fact that it
did it for you at any point yeah it's
concerning I was very connected to these
characters you know it was like
it's like Japanese comes from Japan
no no I watch actual Japanese hentai how
did you find out how did how did you
discover it yeah I remember there was a
guy from in our school who would bring
hentai to school and the teacher's desk
he would walk up when he was asking you
a question oh is this dick head type is
this Ouija this is Ouija yeah you stick
hentai to the front and then no one knew
and then we would just stare at hentai
four lessons
and then after that I was like wow
this guy who knows
he's good he's got the goods we've done
some rap shows where we've reviewed
hentai
I can't remember what I was trying to
download but it was probably some some
music or something and you know instead
of getting like Bill Clinton's like we
did back in the day I just discovered
this hentai and I was like what is this
to find the next episode remember how
you discovered it
it might have been the same honestly I
think it was like yeah it was like oh
yeah no I remember I was at my friend's
place and he was trying to like show me
like this new Linkin Park song or
whatever and uh and he was like oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna let's I'll try and find
an online wire and then he downloaded it
and it was yeah an episode of um [__]
Live Wire yeah of whatever hentai was
and I was just like whoa
this is
and then I went home and searched it up
and that's how I found it because I
didn't even know it was called hentai
you know back in the day right because
like you know that this this was back
when a lot of people didn't know that
anime was called anime hence I was
called hentai was just weird [__]
[__] from China
it's Chinese cartoon yeah yeah and uh I
remember because you know not many
people talked about anime and hentai
back in the day
um and I remember I was out with some
mates out in uh out of the pub and we
were you know getting a few drinks uh
and we were like so guys what's uh
what's the biggest thing that you've
jacked off to that you regret and then
one of my mate goes dude one time I
jacked off to anime porn and everyone's
like oh you're [__] sick mate what
the [__] and I'm just here sitting in
silence being like
um yeah that's uh that's that's weird
man that's mad that's that's weird
that's [__] gross
[Laughter]